a regular
but vision could immediately disguise
himself as a regular husband as easy as
he could try to hide under his hat right
and then he continues the indecent
exposure by walking around unprotected
outside in complete view also yes i
understand that there's surely some
element of magic slash whackiness slash
dreamworld
spoilers going on here so anything could
not be what it seems but you know what
is as it seems
me giving sins whenever the hell i want
to dropping your wife
taking dick van dyke's name in vain or
really taking the name dick van dyke at
all
also how is wanda's dress able to pass
through the chair as well
that's not part of vision's body also
also this chair has no business being in
the middle of the room like this
later we see it doesn't live there so
who dragged this chair out here in the
first place
taking time to dance while the door is
still wide open do you want the
neighbors to see you
in the 50s this is basically the
equivalent to having sex in your
driveway
i see someone went to the mary poppins
school of cleaning things but if you can
control reality why are you even
floating things around or messing with
towels and such
why mess with telekinesis when you just
change actual reality
also this is a neat trick and all but
you also need to dry out the inside of
the glass which you do not appear to be
doing
and that will be a glass of bacteria
before long do you want herpes wanda
because this is how you get ants i mean
herpes also also considering they make
such a big deal about her hiding her
powers from everyone else
maybe don't do this in front of an open
window where any passing neighbor could
see
even if you're making fun of laugh
tracks it's still a laugh track which
means it's still a sin
oh thank you i say oh i don't eat food
well that explains the empty
refrigerator but wanda eats
so that refrigerator should have a few
things in it right well then tell me
what's so important about today's date
can we have a sitcom plot involves a
main character for getting an important
date cliche in a satire slash parody
making fun of the sitcom plot involves
the main character for getting an
important day cliche
and if we do doesn't that just make us a
youtube channel that pokes fun at tv
shows making a cliche out of a cliche
cliche and if so
what even am i do i exist am i a cliche
why is my narration hello dear i'm agnes
your neighbor to the right
my right not yours people that say my
right not yours instead of just saying
to the left
golly you settled in fast did you use a
moving company
agnes just apologized for not visiting
sooner which means it's been at least a
few days since wanda moved in so
what is agnes shocked about the living
room consists of a few pieces of
furniture a coat rack by the front door
and some nicks and a few necks
no it's not a holiday an anniversary
then
yes the tower anniversary
elizabeth olsen is so good at balancing
the old sitcom tone in this but i have
to give her a sin off for it in fact
there's so much that's amazing about
this recreation from the sets to the
camera style to the laugh tracks that i
should probably go ahead and give
several sins off but
honestly you made me think of laugh
tracks as a positive thing so just be
happy with the one removal show
the only way ralph would remember our
anniversary is if there was a beer named
june
2nd but how would that help them
remember you might remember the beer was
named june 2nd but that wouldn't
guarantee the significance would dawn on
him and if you're remembering important
things like anniversaries while
consuming alcohol you're not beering
right
and let me tell you what ralph could
really use is how to goose your wife so
you don't
lose your wife pretending goose rhymes
with lose hey the music isn't bothering
you is it pal
in terms of distraction from work or the
largely nonsensical nature of the lyrics
nonsensical what's so nonsensical about
take out the papers or the trash or you
don't get no spending cash yakity yak is
a pretty straightforward song about
parents ordering around their kids
it's not like someone's asking who put
the bomb in the bomb
ba bomp but also who did put the bomb in
the bomb
bomb and which bomb of the three bombs
are they even responsible for
also i think i just send music somebody
should make a youtube channel that does
that
also also playing music of any kind at
your desk in a shared office what is it
we're producing
computational forms then when vision
asks norm what they did there why didn't
he reply with this
norm even said they didn't make anything
but clearly they're making computational
forms
no skeletons in your closet abition if
he goes through the trouble of creating
a false identity why wouldn't he just
give himself a more normal name
like carl well you're not darling i
still get a little tongue-tied
he is after all this
time couple thinks they're talking about
two different things but the
conversation still somehow works to
maintain the miscommunication cliche
and yes that's likely the point but
consider it a sin for the cliche even
existing in the first place
is your husband tired of you burning his
toast commercials
seriously someone should make a youtube
channel that sends those also this
lobster looks like it
and with this chicken hanging above it
it's clear that this room goes by the
1950s to
10 o'clock standard of interior design
also also parody of a commercial within
the parody of a sitcom and i'm sure when
this is all said and done we'll be wowed
by the ingenious nature of the whole
thing but right now my brain is over
parodied in an over parody brain leads
to horrible things
like watching two and a half men
marathons struggles are real people
oh and now you're using color in a black
and white world is an indicator that
something is different i think someone
saw pleasantville too many times and if
i remember my pleasant villain correctly
this means the toaster has recently
masturbated
how very atmospheric and fire hazardy
guess who look mistakes happen i once
patted the butt of a woman because she
looked like my wife from behind but
there are so many context clues that
this isn't vision that this makes
absolutely no sense
including oh i don't know the other
human woman in the room
we don't break bread with [ __ ]
that's bolshevist
and marxist and communist that man
through there is my boss mr heart
and since you're keeping your voice at
top volume he can hear all of this
explanation
and i'm sure everything will be resolved
and there will be no more hijinks to
maneuver
the heart on the calendar was an
abbreviation
you move at the speed of sound and i can
make a pen float through the air who
needs to
abbreviate wanda would be excellent at
tv sins the candle is the music that's
stunning outfit i understand vision is
some sort of fleshy android ai thing and
there's probably some way you could
simulate sexual desires but it doesn't
make me any less weirded out by it
although it's still less odd than the
sweater he wore in captain america civil
war
i might have a better idea oh sure when
you need to change out of your clothes
you make it happen with a snap
but when you need to cook dinner you'll
go back to pretending you have to do
things telekinetically
just asking for some consistency here
let's take out the papers and the trash
even if mrs hart turned around in time
before seeing any of wanda's powers
mr hart would still be able to see the
display from his position in the living
room
well why don't we have a nice sing-along
all together then shall we convenient
ukulele is convenient
oh no too much
oh no not enough is the opposite of an
overcooked chicken a couple dozen eggs
even if it's not an undercooked chicken
shouldn't it just be one egg
wouldn't you know what good news is more
expensive 24-hour cable news networks
it might be breakfast for dinner but
drinking wine with any kind of breakfast
serving is gross
and also a sin where did you two move
from
what brought you here how long have you
been married and why don't you have
children yet
nosy neighbors i will now be googling
the name babs digby for the next hour or
so
trying to figure out if it's a clue as
to where the show is headed so am i
sending a show for inspiring me to do
some research
yeah i am plot tease cliffhangers cheese
hangers
having a personal radio speaker facing
away from you missed that one the last
time so thank goodness for the
previously on segment
spoiler logos or splogos if you will as
in yes marvel continues to use a full 35
seconds each episode to participate in a
masturbatory cacophony of visuals below
going
separate beds without a shared
nightstand between them it's almost like
the show needs the space empty for a bed
combining joke later
are you using your powers to turn on the
light better question
why haven't we blocked the light
streaming into the window that's forced
me to wear an eye pillow
one to die yes dear
get the light pulling the blankets all
the way over your head to have sex
since when do you need more than one
person at a time under there see the
problem with this is that it probably
means something else this isn't a simple
star and moon moment this is a hint to a
deeper lore that only the bravest of
marvel nerds will know
i wanna know too i don't wanna google
every damn thing
like this or this or this or this
i continue to be bewitched by how
perfectly these episodes imitate the
opening titles of the era it's set in
but i can't just be taking sins off
willy-nilly so
um scene does not contain an elizabeth
montgomery nose wiggle
letting the water run after you're out
of the shower fred and linda are
building a moat in a fully functioning
portcullis and no one even knows why
but then the show never lets us see fred
and linda's moat in portcullis
oh was that a metaphor
ruining the mystery of magic
the way these first episodes layer in
the mystery while creating such a
perfect recreation of the sitcoms of the
past is not only quite a balancing act
to pull off it's honestly a pretty bold
and strange choice
props to marvel for not taking the weird
out of comic book storytelling
take your sin back you senor scratchy
just
loves the stage he played baby jesus in
last year's christmas pageant
isn't having a rabbit play jesus just a
hair sacrilegious
also naming your rabbit senior scratchy
dottie is the key to
everything in this town noted and so
help me if this doesn't turn out to be
true and i'm obsessing over far too many
details i will
never take this sin back just mind your
p's and q's and you're gonna do
just fine i was today years old when i
realized ps and q's stands for pleases
and thank yous
and this is a sin for an educational
system that failed me leaving your
baseball bat outside how are you gonna
defend yourself from a burglar now
i'm sorry daddy i didn't ask about the
chairs so you better not ask me if you
can
share any committees in the future
overselling your puns
i love seat based puns too but you gotta
couch that stuff in subtly to cushion
the blow
anything else is just lazy boy the
devil's in the details bev
like the t-glass that was clearly on the
table behind bev but when she walks away
from the table it's missing
pardon me is this a neighborhood watch
meeting if it is and
it is it shouldn't be a meeting where
nearly 10 people are discussing town
events should not be happening in the
middle of a library where silence is
expected
move that meeting to a private room no
vision new business
actually means another round of danish
it does not
in any context mean this okay for us
take a big red
oh well hold on there a second did you
hear the man he doesn't eat food
but then he clarified and then the laugh
track laughed and this is a dumb thing
to say
well my understanding is that it's
purely for mastication oh no i don't do
that
confusing mastication with masturbation
which honestly leads
to very uncomfortable sexual experiences
so i've heard
this gum looks way too happy to have
been chewed up and swallowed why are you
so happy big red
why
okay i'm digging the mystery i really am
but when do we start getting some
answers oh i know i'll just binge the
rest of the season now so i can get some
relief
let's see where is this on disney plus
is it
wait is this not no
also no wait how does a housewife get a
blood stain out of white linen
by doing it herself forgetting the the
same way she climaxes part of the joke
stretch watch bands mixed with arm hair
ouch
like stroker from the comics and it says
hydra and it's set to 242
and the shape of the four looks like a
knife and it says 1 000 meters and i for
sure know what all of this means but i
totally don't want to spoil it for you
guys
trucker but also doesn't the um change
the u to more of a
u sound so shouldn't this be like
streaker
or something my point is you can add
fancy dots to a u and not change the
pronunciation
vision's intestinal issues are far worse
than expected his gears have swapped
sides from earlier
and for our final act i give you
wanda and vision roll commercials
whoa that's never happened before i
didn't even know i had those powers um
yeah anyway they said the title of the
show so uh do the thing
i was just playing with his shoes
paul benny is absolutely slaying this
illusion ah master of enigma
allow me this piano is clearly still
three-dimensional after she does her
finger wiggle
even though later we see it's not is
this god
this is this your card's on for some
time i'm doing it
is that how near sharita from donnie
darko would be
excellent at tv sins what's in the box
what's in the box in the box i
swear to the tv gods if they open that
box and pepper potts comes out i'm
giving back every sin gladly
what is going on with you i have no idea
i've been feeling
weirdy all day except he knows exactly
what happened
he wasn't asleep when he swallowed the
gum he searched his mouth for it
immediately
it wasn't so hard to fit in after all
title of my sex tape
no hijacking the remote
spending 37 seconds on a recap of two
episodes that hit barely an hour between
them we don't have to be spoon-fed our
television especially when it would take
about two seconds to research anything
we have a question on
you would think at this point they would
know how to spell dc correctly i mean
it's two letters
this guy has terrible hand to cone
placement a bite or two of that ice
cream is going to have this dude's
finger sweat all over it
[Music]
it is not also we should absolutely sin
anytime someone hastily assembles a
swing set
sure sure vision is incredibly fast and
powerful but look if you rush these
things then kids get hurt
being this excited about spending your
day with your bros basking in books
casually reading cervix related material
when you should be watching where you're
walking
we let the little ladies keep tabs on
their growing babies with fruit
makes it simple for them i'm gonna let
denae take this one
you doctor dude at five months a papaya
six grapefruit
seven pineapple eight honeydew
and before i go get the [ __ ] out of here
with that excitement
about anything the size of anything
taking up space
in the body and eventually popping out
especially when it's the size of a
honeydew melon
shove that in your pool [ __ ]
if they're keeping this a secret then
what was up with all the flaunting in
the opening credits
in fact how would those opening credits
events even occur considering she's
pregnant for less than a day before the
babies are delivered
slicing through concrete with an
electric hedge trimmer you've gotten
bigger
even in a heightened crazy scenario such
as this i feel like it's still
inappropriate to ask a woman this
question
i can't wait
to be a proud papaya dad jokes
vision insinuated when the doctor was
there they just found out wanda was
pregnant 12 hours prior
so when did they go buy all the baby
furniture having a pregnant woman around
paint fumes no matter how wonderful the
family-owned company might be
also not sure why but this paint really
makes me think about how much i prefer
last crusade over raiders
well i guess there's only one solution
to this debate
hope for a girl thinking that having a
girl will solve parental debates
if you're keeping the doll clothes on
while practicing diaper changing skills
why take off the shoes at all phil
do these earrings make me look fat oh
thank god
asking if earrings make you look fat i
think something's wrong here
i think something is wrong here cliche
yes dear i think my water just broke
metaphorical amniotic showers do you
need a break
i mean i feel like you also need to help
strain that dog but you do you
i rolled my eyes when i saw this four
ounces on the luxury bath powder box
because ounces is most often abbreviated
as oz
and doesn't need the s on the end but
then my dumb ass looked up for
ozs and that led me to this page of
scientific mumbo jumbo check it out
40zs has synthetic construct listed here
and so help me i can't help but wonder
if this is purposeful
this show man this show it's 75 degrees
out you making a fashion statement
says the woman wearing long sleeves in a
very fashionable vest
i gotta borrow a bucket not to wear to
use
somehow all the pipes in my ceiling
burst at once pretty sure that requires
a lot more assistance than a single
bucket could provide
thank you as if geraldine wasn't acting
fishy enough with her fishy pants they
go ahead and give her an apple to be
sure we know she's an [ __ ]
here's the thing maybe geraldine does
see the stork and it's gonna be revealed
later why she's not bringing attention
to it but all i have to go on is the
present and i'm sending the
out of geraldine's peripheral vision
because it is non-existent
if she's already seen the nursery is
there really a reason to still be
covering the baby bump
bermuda awaits and my car decides to
poop out right
at this moment but you can't drive to
bermuda and you could get a cab to the
airport or cruise ship so not sure why
this is a huge issue
but stan what about my brand new
two-piece maybe before you get
comfortable sitting in the car waiting
for stan to fix it you can hop to it and
finish the packing job
so this is all that happens when she
actually gives birth when she had a
contraction she caused all the power to
go out in the neighborhood and when she
broke her water everyone's house flooded
but when she gives birth
a vacuum turns on and the fireplace
lights up for a second and i'm certain
there should be
lava erupting and flowing in the streets
hey doc
why don't you help me out in the kitchen
there or you know
stitch up some vaginal tearing and check
to be sure the placenta comes out
without issue
oh we're going to continue to gloss over
the very real parts of birth
you're strong and really clean have you
seen a baby right after it's born
there's more bodily fluids on newborn
babies than on even the most active
participants at most exorcism orgies
allow me to walk you out doctor you said
knock you out oddly and considering this
doctor represents some triggering
chauvinistic behavior i think you should
speak very clearly
well i'll go back to wonder i know
there's a strange vibe in the air but
cheese and crackers you just saw your
wife give birth to twin boys a day after
showing signs of pregnancy let's have
some priorities vision
geraldine survives this this slow motion
undusting scene is so very cool but
again brings up so many questions
and since the sims channels have already
had a few swings at this let's just
focus instead on the story of 44 year
old ronald j
tesh of republic missouri on the day of
the snap ronald was walking his farm
with his wife when he disintegrated
right in front of her eyes
a year later the still grieving widow
had to sell the land to amazon for a
distribution center
and take a job there as a line
supervisor four years after that on the
day of the reverse snap she was doing
her daily checks just as her late
husband reappeared
standing in the midst of the mechanical
jungle his confused look didn't last
long as his upper torso was split by the
assembly belt now occupying that space
and his wife watched his now bisected
lifeless corp slowly proceed through the
now gruesome assembly line
so great job avengers
this subtitle implies that monica rambo
is in fact maria rambo's daughter who is
a character from captain marvel but it's
hard to make out what the off-screen
voice is saying and if you don't have
the subtitles on you're more likely to
miss that captain marvel is the one
that's talking if the reveal is supposed
to be a surprise down the road then a
sin for secret spoiling subtitles and if
this is supposed to be pertinent
information then a sin for needing the
subtitles on
yes i know i'm complicated not watching
where you're blipping
but dr highland i think i can't believe
it
where did you go one of the brilliant
things about the connectedness of the
mcu is the ripples of reveals like this
now that we know monica got dusted when
you watch in-game the captain marvel
stuff becomes even more personal it's
honestly an incredible tool in their
belt and props to marvel for
understanding the power of complex canon
building
wait what this is a marvel property i'm
watching
it's bad enough i have to remember what
shield means which for the record
i do not now you're throwing sword at me
too too many acronyms marvel i'm over
acronymed
also sentient weapon observation
response division may be the dumbest
acronym ever
a full division dedicated to the
response to observing sentient weapons
how many sentient weapons are we dealing
with here also also
if i'm understanding the people who
would prefer i pronounce jif gif then
this should actually be pronounced
sward since the o stands for observation
good to know i'll make sure i do that
from here on out i work here
if you did you're badger work wouldn't
it i know there are apple leaders out
there working reception desks but
considering
billions of people just reappeared on
the earth a couple weeks ago this kind
of response seems like it's more to set
up the
you know this is cliche rather than
anything approaching reality
we have an agent a day it was five years
not fifty
unless she was seven expecting someone
to have aged visibly in five years is
just silly and if it's just some lame
attempt at blip humor well i'm sending
your delivery
getting stuck with the nickname photon
it also says observation and response on
that door
it's not creation the world's not the
same as you left it
there is nothing more exciting in a
superhero series than a discussion about
corporate prioritization
the fbi isn't a tizzy over a missing
persons case of new jersey
missing persons i know but they've
requested use of one of our imaging
drones
but wouldn't a request like that require
more information sward is an
organization that has to deal with
situations on a galactic level
why would they be interested in helping
out the fbi in this capacity with this
little knowledge going in
new jersey james ewoo fbi
did you see that he did the card trick
ant-man showed him man
i can't keep taking sins off for these
marvel links so here's a sin for
show taking three full episodes to
randall park and kat dennings
i guess pardon me sheriff would you mind
repeating your claim about west
view to my colleague here no such place
many mysteries from the previous three
episodes get solved over the next half
hour
still one puzzle not pieced together is
how the local law enforcement would be
under wanda spell but wu and rambo
aren't they're standing in front of the
same sign the police officers are also
how has
no one else driven into westview before
now maybe the town isn't on a major road
but it's still on a road that could be a
shortcut for someone looking to shave
off a few minutes of their commute did
all those people get a makeover and a
new identity
these reveals are exciting but they also
make one wonder if wanda's plan isn't
terrible
i think wanda's plan might be terrible
why haven't you gone inside to
investigate
because it doesn't want me to oh
growing up other kids had michael jordan
posters on their walls but i had elliott
ness
where would you even find an elliot nest
poster pre-internet and yes i know the
untouchables was a popular movie in the
late 80s but those would be kevin
costner posters
scene only contains one broke girl also
how many mcu movies do we have to
remember to keep the names and
connections of the sporting characters
straight
at least the avengers movies stuck
mainly with the big guns if you
immediately recall who darcy lewis or
jimmy wu is i salute you but i shouldn't
need a cheat sheet to understand your
show
sward response base isn't response
already in the acronym
why not just call it the sward
divisional base for observation in
response
this is truly some top-notch terrible
acronyming
those drones you're sending in what kind
of data are you getting
the beginning of this episode
annihilation's so hard that if cat
dennis doesn't eventually find some sort
of nightmare bear roar screaming the
word
drone i'm gonna be severely disappointed
also
drones you guys look like you might get
down with those little pod things
horrendous for the environment
technically this is a true statement
but k-pods are also recyclable so this
is more about laziness than
environmental concern darcy
while the crew cut does seem like an
[ __ ] you didn't actually ask for
assistance
there's no reason to suspect the
perimeter doesn't extend subterraneously
jimmy would be fresh off the boat at tv
since so you're saying the universe
created a sitcom starring two avengers
show includes confused fan ramblings
frustrated at not being able to binge
the whole season of wand division have
some patience you spoiled streamer
babies
wait it's ending i mean i know you
wanted to wink back at the mid-credit
easter egg of the first episode but when
we first see the show they're at the
start of the boss visits for dinner
scene which was a good 10 minutes before
the show's credits and considering this
entire real-time conversation lasts
less than three minutes i think you may
have fudged on the show timeline quite a
bit there
whiteboard from the sins writing room
desperately trying to figure out how to
sin a mystery in real time is somehow
transported onto the show
wait a second have we even seen this i
don't think it's in the first two so
does this mean there might be another
episode of the bewitched or dick van
dyke style
shows are you holding out on us d plus
release the dick cut
what that's honestly not the worst way
that could have gone wanda
can you read me over this kind of works
but then in the episode she somehow
rewound out of this moment
so what happened to this guy when she
did that if real objects and people get
integrated into the time period
fine but i'm presenting that we will
likely never get an explanation to the
paradox of the timing of all this
and if we do then i'll be happy to take
a sin back okay i'll begrudgingly take a
sin back
okay fine i'll pretend to take us in
back and then make some snarky comment
and actually addison instead
happy now seriously a whole staff set up
to painstakingly watch episodes of
television to break them down looking
for meaning in minutia
are we really supposed to believe such a
place would exist
twins but they shouldn't know that yet
in the previous episode rambo delivered
the one baby and then they discovered a
second one was coming after vision came
in with the doctor
but where's rambo not answering this
question was some variation of
probably in a headband off brutally
killing some people in a jungle
somewhere in the name of justice
once again i have to ask how wanda's
powers work at times she can make
something appear with the snap of her
fingers
so why couldn't she simply make monica
disappear now wanda has more unnecessary
cleanup just snap your fingers
you've done it several times so far why
would wanda see this version of vision
this would mean he's dead and he isn't
dead he is perfectly fine and everyone
will be happy and how dare they try to
make any of us believe otherwise
there hasn't been a route 2 in new
jersey since 1942.
it's all wonderful repeating your
misdirection from the previous episode
hoping it will stick
slow going one of the most orgasmic
moments in mcu history
splurgasming parts of this episode
especially those stairs and the opening
credits running through the park have
super duper full house vibes which is
honestly a dick move by elizabeth here
it wasn't enough she had to usurp her
twin sister's fame she has to own the
only thing they had left
if you go to sleep i promise you will be
my favorite
twin sibling favoritism whether joking
or not this can really [ __ ] up a kid's
identity
i mean probably not more than skipping
entire developmental stages but still
keep it down leslie's about to get my
leg over getting my leg over
also horny viz continues to be horny and
look we're totally sex positive around
here but i'm also 100
sex positive you should probably put the
infants down first
look i think it's working expecting a
baby to suck on a binky coated in
synthetic ear wax i was just fluffing
this
pillow with my face seriously viz enough
with the sexual euphemisms
do you want to take that again breaking
character you're better than that
catherine
honestly i can't believe they left that
in fussy babies meet
buns of steel we dare you to stay away
for the life of me i can't think of a
way her buns of steel will play into
quieting these babies that isn't making
me
extremely uncomfortable lavender
supposed to have a calving effect
spraying anything onto an infant without
researching first to be sure that the
supposed to is an absolutely will
looking at the fruit bowls here i'm
reminded of how often fruit goes bad in
my house and before you head to the
comments to complain about that not
being a sin on this show it absolutely
is
look at all those apples vision and wand
are the only apple eating [ __ ] in
this house
anything over five is just over fruiting
the more you look at this picture the
more it seems like your head was
photoshopped onto the wrong part of
someone else's body
once you see it you can't unsee it i
mean it's probably a real picture but
weren't there better pictures to choose
[Music]
[Laughter]
baby vision i'm only human guys but also
this is giving me serious enemy mind
vibes and i'm not okay with that
oh sure tommy's name has nothing but
billy's name gets the exclamation point
this is clearly more favoritism and
ultimately just creates poor family ties
this random tiger on the table combined
with agnes bragging there's no
taming this tiger is two bengal
references in less than 10 minutes and
this is exactly the kind of show that
makes me spend 20 minutes thinking about
what it means
and that's 20 minutes i could have been
mining bitcoin damn it
there's a briefing in 10 pants are
encouraged but not
mandatory what sort of operation is this
people can just free ball or go clam
mando willy-nilly
i need another blood draw no no no we're
done here
and because we aren't supposed to know
about monica's abnormalities yet this
works
translucent privacy curtains that used
to be opaque so you can't open
it's an oversimplification of events but
yes
what in a tv show you
don't say monica should blast you
halfway across new jersey hyperbole
bring up the visual this entire
conversation has been the typical mcu
convenient self-advancing powerpoint
presentation
but suddenly somebody needs to be
instructed to pull something up and they
have it ready with a few clicks
why wasn't that in the original file
also it's a good thing that this console
self-orients so that wherever the camera
is we aren't looking at it upside down
but that's in direct violation of
section 36b of the sokovia accords
[Music]
just imagine being this guy in the
background your only job as an extras to
stare at the back of deputy derpy's head
and look like you're desperately trying
to hold in a fart
all right that's it for now wow what a
waste of a debrief
this reminds me of attending staff
meetings where 98 of what is being
covered doesn't concern you at all
great you informed everyone who wanda is
why she's dangerous and that she stole a
carcass i mean the carcass part is new
but is it all so exciting
that literally everyone had to stop
their important work to listen
you know i don't miss the crying but
geez louise did you have to learn to
walk
you two never stay put but there are kid
crafts on the fridge so clearly they can
sit still long enough to make
all this um art oh look the lobster
penis is back and now it has more
friends
this fish looks like another penis and
i'm not even sure what this is but
dragon maybe anyhow it's clear this room
goes by the 1980s too
duck abstract art and a heart standard
of interior design my kitchen window
told me someone got a new pooch
windows can't talk that a hunch someone
might pop over
with exactly the item we require
this talking toaster would be excellent
at tv sins
vision gets on to wanda for being
careless with her powers but earlier we
saw him dressed for family portrait day
at sears
as a turkey the easter bunny and santa
while still looking very much android
rambo is trying to figure out how to get
back into westview via some complex
thingamajig and honestly i'm not sure
why she's concerned
clearly suarez has many amazing things
at their disposal they can pop up a
sweet tent city at a moment's notice and
their standard issue uniforms include
neat little thumb cutouts
if you can do thumb cutouts what can't
you do this wall has turned from useful
way to track information on who's in
town to
why is there a whole row of wand and
vision at the top when they're already
in the center
someone's patting their serial killer
board she could have taken out thanos on
her own if he hadn't initiated a blitz i
mean
nobody else came close well i'd argue
that captain marvel came close
read it what are we looking for that
you're looking for the thing that just
happens to be set up on display in this
room right where you need it for
storytelling purposes
cool checks out are we being mind
controlled to see that right now
i mean she was wearing them when she
exited so this is a question you may
have wanted to ask when rambo was found
in the field
not naked can i borrow this whoa whoa
whoa whoa
this is a beyond reprehensible act by a
character we're supposed to love
it needlessly puts equipment and even
lives at risk for a display that has
already been confirmed by a test anyway
this is both reckless and pointless and
the only sane resolution to this choice
involves monica and handcuffs and
immediately removed from the case and
the agency
also no one hears the shots that are
fired despite this being a bustling base
nobody comes running to see what
shenanigans are afoot despite being on
high alert
honestly this scene may be the most
unbelievable part of this entire series
so you're telling me this is a
typewriter a rolodex and a calendar
all-in-one
don't forget that it's also a place to
discover copious amounts of pornographic
images
and considering vision's apparent sexual
insatiability in the series you
know that's the first place he would go
what else can it do find me a wife
eventually yes
so vision knows the future and if so how
does he not know he's dead
i mean mostly dead or temporarily dead
but in no way dead forever and ever
you have to stop her stop who she's in
my head
look marvel we can spot pronoun gaming a
mile away and our city senses are
all over this use of her and she so take
your sin for pronoun gaming and for
teasing us with this wanda or agnes
conundrum when we might have to wait
weeks for the answer
also this guy is briefly outside the
puppet masters control and my question
is
does that mean he can see he's talking
to a walking android corpse
something's scaring him assuming you can
understand a dog whimper
stay here disobedience
we can't see the drone on the broadcast
wand is framing it out of the shot
since when are the broadcasts you're
watching happening in concurrent real
time
disregard take the shot take the shot
with the missile that you have attached
to a drone built in the 80s
was the missile from the 80s too and if
so what sort of magical mumbo jumbo had
to happen for suar to find a drone from
the 80s just lying around in a nearby
new jersey warehouse
wait is it night outside the dome but
day inside we see earlier that it's
clearly bright out but out here it's
pitch black
i get that wanda or whoever could do
this but we've seen it be night on the
show before and later it's clearly night
in the town behind her
the missile was just a precaution this
guy is it just me or these shots
targeting her cleavage a bit more than
her heart
geez even the laser sights are a bit
male gazy lagos
for when you make a mess you didn't mean
to that slogan second only to lagos
so strong even overly metaphorical blood
stains don't even stand a chance
ah don't worry he's sure to turn up your
mom won't let him get far
ma'am an important unknown character has
an unnecessary speaking line to set up
their existence for later cliche
by the way you can use this casual
superfluous introduction theory to spot
the killer in almost every single one of
the over 1000 various csi episodes what
i'm saying is watch out for the mailman
he's obviously the killer
don't age yourselves up why would this
be a response from the kids
what would growing up do to fix the dead
dog you can't control me the way you do
them
can't the way wanda in this show uses
this role credits moment to play into
both the story and themes of denial and
grief that are prevalent throughout this
whole episode
is such brilliant work that i have to
give another sin off keep it up marvel
and the mtu may rival the mcu
i wonder who is this asks the man who
despite being adamant about it the
entire episode is suddenly completely
unconcerned about revealing his identity
to strangers
[Applause]
what this masturbatory logo spewing
keeps going on and on week after week
most shows cut down their opening
credits after a few episodes but this is
just the [ __ ] logo crawl
this kind of display is the equivalent
of the ubu dog barking at us every week
for 30 full seconds
make it stop if you end up with this
much toothpaste sauce outside your mouth
you're simply toothpasting wrong
oh yes i remember all those early aught
family sitcoms that had a close-up of
the neighbor's ass in the opening
credits
halloween's a magical holiday halloween
episode's in february
where's your costume tommy this is my
costume i'm the cool twin
costume slackers adoratosaurus rex not a
real dinosaur the dorkasaurus racks
would fit right in the middle at tv
sins mixing your rubiks with your jenga
everyone knows competitive jingx wasn't
invented until 2014.
he's your uncle why would i be scared
because it's four o'clock in the
afternoon you're secretly afraid he's a
vampire
but why would they think that pietro is
a vampire if he's able to sleep in a
room full of sunshine unharmed
i think kids
[Applause]
to be fair i'll take a fish over a
toothbrush or those weird brown and
orange wrapped candies
that's not exactly how i remember it
except according to your own look before
cutting to
it you are the one remembering it if
this was pietro's memory why did we cut
from your blatant memory face
you probably suppressed a lot of the
trauma we've already mentioned the fun
marvel winks the easter egg teasing the
incredible design work and the acting
that make these homages such a success
but have we talked about how incredibly
they continue to layer in the themes of
trauma and denial it allows the show to
maintain both surface frivolity and
meaningful depth and damn
i'm about to give another sin back
aren't i and he's what you call
a man-child finger quoting words that
don't
need them also licking your fingers ever
again
ever you are incorrigible darling i know
you
have a secret thing for mexican
wrestlers
this sexual tension is leading somewhere
right like they certainly wouldn't build
this up every single episode and then
not give us some sort of payoff
wait is the final episode an homage to
californication is it
where to keep your water balloons who
asked the question this way wouldn't you
just simply ask where do you keep your
balloons
who stores balloons with water already
in them pietro's tattoo looks like it
says mom but i think it says hom
which we all know stands for house of m
which is of course a reference to house
of
mouse in the mickey mouse clubhouse so
hot dog hot dog here's a hot diggity sin
for yet more pointless disney synergy
and which one of you is the sassy best
friend it's funny because it's true
i haven't seen disney's cell phone this
hard since carts 3 ended up trying to
teach a lesson about crass commercialism
god help me i'm going to talk about the
timing again because this tv shows the
first portion of the episode we are
currently watching even though in the
real world this meeting appears to be
the same night as the drone attack so
is this episode happening now for the
first time and if so why aren't they all
watching it for clues
and if not how are the events
intersecting when it's mid-afternoon on
tv
and still night here i feel like you
just want the episodes playing on the
random tvs as filler but no one has
given a single consideration to the
process of how
and when these episodes air all you
people who left
still have the luxury of optimism
you have no idea what it was like what
it took to keep the lights on
then maybe you should have told her all
about this instead of just sending her
on a mission her first day back
maybe it's a good thing you weren't here
when your mother died
because clearly you don't have the
stomach for this job here's the thing
i'm okay with hayward turning out to be
a bad guy but
this is the guy who was doing everything
he could just a few episodes ago to get
rambo
out of the wanda sitcom world and is now
willing to shuck her aside so
he can play war i'm just saying a little
growth of the character would have been
excellent
why didn't anyone tell me the plan the
better question is how did anyone have
time to tell
anyone the plan convenient suare panchos
are convenient look i know you want me
to pronounce it differently but you're
not the boss of me now and you're not so
big
life isn't fair trick-or-treating in the
daytime kick-ass
yeah you know yet another marvel movie
property that has both aaron taylor
johnson
and evan peters what does it all mean
all the canyon has disappeared stealing
and all the jack-o'-lanterns have been
smashed vandalism
now everyone's covered in silly strings
and
bullying it's the rare how to turn your
characters from likable to [ __ ]
trifecta
sorry what i gotta bounce to where
exactly at least some of that
went down right where herb is standing
this show got intensely dark
it's like they took the dread of get out
but took the laser accurate social
commentary about racism in america and
replaced it with
um sitcom superhero stuff so
yay i've seen plenty of creepy things in
this job but this kid's left thumbnail
is flat out the most horrific thing in
the history of human existence
it hurts to even look at it make it go
away
pretending that the face decomposes at a
different rate than the rest of the body
marquee refuses to indicate if we are
lindsay lohanning or haley milzing
also in this universe who even voices
frozone they've got
full-sized candy bars a few blocks up
mom can we go
next stop cavity town i mean it's cool
in all that tommy has super speed but
he was only able to grab two candy bars
lame
oh how cute these kids went for
halloween as ruth bader ginsburg in the
current american justice system
totes adorbs this cul-de-sac has the
most extended driveways in the history
of sack bottoms that's just poor city
planning why even have a cul-de-sac in
the first place
oh no one leaves wanda won't even let us
think about it
but wanda will let you think about
thinking about leaving my way back into
the hex will be here in an hour
just gotta meet my guy over the ridge
you know at some point this tantric
pronoun gaming could just be considered
audience abuse just tell us it's reed
richard so we can climax already
worst case scenario wanda removes my
free will and puts me in ultra low rise
jeans
right that's what i was thinking worst
case scenario
hayward has your blood work there are a
thousand different files i could be
looking at right now but i happen to be
looking at your blood work
on the off chance you may make a
declaration about wanting to travel into
the hex again
the energy inside has rewritten your
cells on a molecular level twice
it's changing you like i don't know
mutating them
just say it marvel say it
hey i'm not some stranger obvious
cover-up lie is obvious
hayward you sneaky bastard giving your
secret file the designation of
eyes only and then attaching your name
to it we know that the city is several
miles around but
thankfully for the plot vision decided
to emerge right by the main outpost
and within short walking distance from
the server farm where darcy has been
hacking unhindered all night
are they showing night of the living
dead in this town square sure it's a
great choice because it's public domain
and all but now i have to know who's
controlling this so i know why their
movie choices are so on the nose
a metaphorical representation of disney
engulfing fox
somehow makes it into the show yeah yeah
yeah opening logos blah blah blah but
can we talk about
how in addition to this 90 seconds of
previously on and logoing that we also
end with over four minutes of credits
that's almost six minutes of not wanda
visioning
now i have to do math every time i look
at the runtimes on d plus and figure out
if i actually do have time to squeeze an
episode in before my friday colonic
and it's hard to work that out sometimes
[Music]
oh yes let's pretend that last night
wanda would expand the boundaries of her
hex to save vision but then not actually
go find him and ensure that he's alive
[Music]
setting aside that uno isn't even a
video game it was only invented about
five years before the atari why not go
with pong controllers
that had been around in some form since
the 60s even if you don't do video games
go with a paddle ball or
marbles or regular old playing cards i'm
just saying when thinking about how many
choices you had here you certainly had
more than uno
mom my head feels weird it's like
really noisy i don't like it
resting her eyes
ignoring a clear sign that your child is
in need of supernatural medical
attention
i plan on taking a quarantine style
staycation sorry wanda you don't get to
call a pleasant break away from your
kids a quarantine
not in 2021 you don't you never even put
on a mask
sure jokes hearty heart but everyone
else's clothes have changed and even
your hair is different i get that
someone is producing all this but we've
also been led to believe that the
anomaly itself changes material things
to match the era automatically so we
should clearly be in pajama territory
here
aha cane cola more clues
this is obviously a reference to scrooge
mcduck who walks with a cane
come on disney these tie-ins are getting
to be a bit much on a completely
unrelated note i wonder if cane cola
comes in a six-pack
also where's the food there are two
shelves here dedicated to beverages
alone where are the leftover containers
and yes i know vision doesn't eat but
you had your bushels of fruit in the 80s
so
at least throw some lunchables in here
listen if you're going to use the box
for clever metaphors like
vision starting at the edge of town at a
circus and needing to get to the center
of town to his wife
or calling it sugar snaps in reference
to the infinity snaps
why not use all the box for cleverness
unless of course repeating these
nutrients four times in a row
is a clue which it isn't also where's
the riboflavin
a simple moment that is absolutely my
favorite from this episode with the milk
changing from milk from 1950 i would
have send it if you didn't give it the
quick smell test
but you did and i smiled dang it
elizabeth stop being so good at this
lying setting unrealistic beauty
standards my god who wakes up looking
this
good no one okay no one hidden mickeys
can i help you creeper you don't
remember me from last night
who's the real creeper here vision's
been passed out in the field all night
and all you
guys are just out here clowning around
what wii game is this
and how is this interface even a
two-player game also setting up your wii
without the sensor bar in place
also also this is a terrible place for
your tv
who puts the tv in the middle of the
room with two chairs facing away from
the television
also times three this is some of the
worst cord management i've ever seen
apparently this is plugged into the
floor somehow and then you just threw
the mess of cords out in full view
find a wicker basket for that you cord
jumbling chaos monsters
vision is made of vibranium they
literally inherited tough skin
assuming to understand the complexity of
the genetics of your children when they
were born in a fake sitcom in a fantasy
universe
agnes is in full stride here meaning she
knocked on the door and took about six
steps back to strut on in
i'm a little impressed but mostly
annoyed
i'll be fine just go with agnes
parenting i mean my parents once left me
with a family of strangers in l.a so
they could attend a taping of the price
is right and
i'm still here and so very well adjusted
so fine i'm fine
i'm fine our conversations with
ourselves every day of the past pandemic
year somehow make it into the script
the most unbelievable thing in this
email from darcy is that in the rushed
moments to get this to them she took the
time to properly punctuate
each letter in the terrible sward
acronym i didn't even do this in this
subtitle and i had plenty of time it's
just that as any woman can attest to
having to deal with constant periods is
extremely annoying
did we get your specs right yes and
within one day
the well-known efficiency of
governmental agencies comes through
again
fool the guesser games yes please tell
me how old you think i am and how much
you think i weigh
can we go to the would you like to get
kicked in the balls or punched in the
booth next
please and who is that imposter pietro
vision is like the third person already
in this episode to plot jesus with this
question and we get it marvel another
big reveal is coming at this point
you're building it up so much i'd be
disappointed if pietro isn't revealed in
the final shot as hugh jackman flipping
the middle claw and dropping an f-bomb
at a local westview bar
you're not supposed to talk considering
we never once hear the interviewers in
modern family the sitcom this episode is
mostly based on
i think one has a point here and
therefore would be excellent at tv
sins a unique antidepressant that works
to anchor you back to your reality
or the reality of your choice get it
multiple realities
you could even call them virtual
realities it's clear now
with this in the video games earlier
that wand is going to create nexus
which as we all know will be the name of
a virtual reality headset where she and
super horny vision can have lots of sex
guys i'm getting super good at picking
up on these easter eggs
she's gonna sail right through unharmed
obvious overconfident premature
celebration is premature
and obvious i can get through and i
won't be needing this anymore
so wanda killed me a full minute
rehashing a moment we already saw in the
movie being referenced i didn't realize
the
infinity in infinity war referred to how
long marvel would continue to refer back
to it in its properties
take a lesson from your own show marvel
move on already oh
and another red light i'll overkill out
the sticks here don't you think
overkill a maybe a little insensitive to
the guy who just learned he was killed
twice
superhero is an obvious superhero
because they know how to land in a
superhero pose cliche
all you do is lie but wouldn't want to
be
slightly interested in how monica is
showing up in sward gear that hadn't
been altered on its way through the hex
which reminds me why weren't her clothes
transported like everything else coming
through
monica herself is a superhuman now but
are her clothes
what am i doing here sitting talking to
you
great question and honestly this has
been building for a while but how does
the timing of any of this make any sense
most of this stuff has been shown to be
really happening so when was this
recorded and why does it take place in
sequence with him flying out of the
truck what is happening when and why and
how and where and when does deathstroke
finally show up
[Music]
nice this show is super fun and
catherine hahn is a treasure and i'm so
glad she's getting to shine here there
are plenty of reasons i could remove
another sin for one division but this
one is for han
solo we did
everyone did and i killed sparky too
bragging about dog murder
this screen not only does it taunt me
every week it's taken me until this
episode to finally realize it's not
saying there will be a mid-credits scene
so this week i'll finally turn off the
show and not stick around hoping for a
scene that never shows up can you
imagine if they waited till the seventh
episode to do any kind of mid-credits
scene good thing that would never happen
this was not previously on wandavision
it was previously on infinity war
i'm way too lazy to go back and check if
they've actually shown this in any
previous episodes but even if they have
you're still breaking the 1978
previously on accords
set in motion when the show alice
petitioned and was denied use of and
alice doesn't live here anymore clip
because christe didn't consider it
cinema
also i was going to stop sinning how
long these previously on segments
continue to be but then you had to go
and title this entire episode previously
on which means this is essentially
40 full minutes of previously on and how
did you ever think you'd get away with
it
in case you confused it with the famous
witch trials of salem oregon yet you
have betrayed your coven
and we will all now take our hoods down
dramatically and simultaneously for
maximum creepiness
i did not break your rules they simply
bent to my
power the new england patriots are they
killing her
taking away her powers giving her
indigestion you don't know when the show
isn't interested in telling you either
but those pretty blue lights sure are
cool huh
now she's purpling they're blue and it's
sucking the life out of them because
purple please
i can be good no you cannot parents
[Music]
kids she does look shocked to meet the
real us doesn't she
oh good we're back to the current day i
was beginning to fear this episode would
be a never-ending parade of flashbacks
with no real story momentum
glad that will never happen that's
adorable
my thoughts are not available to you
jets they never
ever were then how would wanda not know
that before now
and yes i thought about the fact that
agatha could have been supplying wanda
with false thoughts but then i also
decided that if i keep filling in the
blanks for this stuff i'm doing marvel's
job for them
despite the rumors they don't pay me for
this that accent
really comes and goes doesn't it
considering the show has already played
around with this joke hackathon would be
excellent but repetitive at tv sins
i was so patient
waiting for you to reveal your true
self pretending you have great patience
because you waited a few days for the
next episode
i mean new information netflix has
ruined us all also wanda's version of
patience is apparently resurrecting a
dead brother and killing a dog in an
attempt to force wanda to reveal her
powers
i got close with fake pietro vietro if
you will
we'll handle the lazy nicknames around
here agatha snarkness
but you're so crippled by your own
self-doubt that you believed it
look i'm sure there are more pietro
reveals coming but the idea that agatha
would use a completely different person
to imitate wanda's brother on the off
chance that she's so distraught that she
wants to believe it
it's quite the stretch sure it's fun for
us but i can think of at least five
different ways snooper could have
snooped without relying on that long
shot
of course there's transmutation show
decides to pause for a few minutes to
give us agatha's witchcraft and forced
exposition masterclass
magic on autopilot disney's corporate
slogan for its film division
accidentally makes it into the script
but it's time to look at some real
reruns
in the end agatha was always going to
have to do the ghost of christmas pass
routine right
so why did she wait agatha might enjoy
getting to play in wanda's dick van dyke
and bewitched playground but once it got
to the full house her family dies i feel
like agatha should have made her move
and if you're calling pietro a move go
back a few sims and see how we felt
about that
going with the colorized i love lucy set
geez irena maybe step away from the
window you've got the
purge going on two stories down this
might be a better time to take shelter
instead of immersing your world with
dick van dyke
dick van dyke again always sitcom sitcom
sitcom
insta sin haters also what else could
have been picked everything in the
suitcase was a sitcom
here's the sims for disney plus not
releasing their own shows on physical
media now how am i supposed to watch
people watching dvd on dvd on dvd
also this episode is a straight classic
but it's not the one wanda picked
wanda said she wanted to watch episode
21 from the second season which is my
husband
is a check grabber it may look like a
walnut is episode 20.
the tv dvd dvd player both power cords
and the av
connecting cord survive this where'd you
get the big guns
wanda puberty don't be scared you
already lifted once
you said bored wrong and we're focusing
on an infinity stone again i swear they
should have just called them the herpes
stones because this
is never going away do we have to see
wanda watching sitcoms in every scenario
from the past the show sets that aspect
up well with the suitcase full of dvds
and the tv night with world war 3
happening outside the maximoff residence
unless of course this hospital uses the
brady bunch as punishment of some kind
which makes sense because that show is
torture also this seems like
exactly the kind of room that wouldn't
have anything included but a cold
slab table but would also have taken the
time to integrate a color television
with access to the brady bunch
priorities if we're accessing wanda's
memories from these scenes then how are
we seeing this
these moments would have been completely
outside of wanda's vision the broken
pieces of you are adding up buttercup
are they though or are they being
retrofitted this must be that new math
thing i've heard so much about
[Music]
breaking dad i've never experienced loss
because
i've never had a loved one to lose
but what is grief if not love
persevering damn it marvel just as soon
as i'm ready to write off this episode
is a bunch of pointless backstory you
dropped this
vision soup for the soul bomb on me and
i realize how perfectly this episode
represents the process of therapy and
growth
therapy rules and so does this moment
yes sir
yeah she's still here hayward can see
wanda on the screen
so why would he ask the apple leader at
the desk if she's still there one moment
i have to buzz you in
i got it thanks what is the process of
buzzing someone in that you couldn't
have done it in the time it took you to
tell her you needed to buzz her in
also still a dick move by wanda here
either way they said you could head back
it's not going to take long
you can hold a spell i get that
superheroes would have to drive their
normal people buick like a boring person
from time to time but it feels so wrong
to me
it's like a werewolf holding a gun sort
of wrong jeez westview if you aren't
going to take care of that pool at least
drain it
you want mosquitoes because this is how
you get mosquitoes i would have given
all the sins back if we had one scene in
the past of vision being shown
properties by a realtor
for all the pretense of this episode
giving us explanations of how all this
started they really yadda yadda the hell
out of it at the end this outburst of
powers is pure chaos and emotion
for wanting to be able to keep up what
she's doing would require a lot of
control and planning i don't see how
this explains anything for agatha that
she probably didn't already know
not giving your blade runner references
time to register wait where are we now
did she create an actual home or create
a broadcast studio and if this is all in
her mind space then why would she be
imagining a studio with agatha in the
audience seating
why is camera this is chaos magic wanda
but that makes you scarlet witch
[Music]
i'm bored i see d plus took my note from
last week and removed the please stand
by screen
thank you now i know for sure there
won't be a mid-credits scene
i always appreciate the help disney
tried every type of power supply under
the sun
when all we needed was a little energy
directly from the source i love how
simple jay from drop dead diva makes
this sound
sure she zapped our drone so we now know
all the secrets to our energy and how to
capture it and transfer it to a vision
clone
voila if next week's episode isn't
called double vision
we riot previously on wandavision
not saying previously on previously on
the episode previously on want division
also play that again and tell me
elizabeth olson herself doesn't sound
like she's bored with these tediously on
one division segments
previously on wandavision she throws
that voiceover away like it's a gum
wrapper she found in an old jacket
these are runes wanda only the witch
that casts
the runes can use her magic spoiling
your own show by what you put in the
previously on segment
this back-breaking pose he was gonna
burn westview to the ground just to get
what he wants
sure so hayward appears to not be that
great but he may have legitimate reasons
for his actions we don't know
i like that the show leaves his villainy
a bit nuanced and doesn't feel the need
for him to do something truly evil and
drastic like oh i don't know
attempted child murder this is chaos
magic
wand see we know that agatha is bad
because she has extensions dark makeup
in this sock neck
i take power from the undeserving it's
kind of my thing
and kind of vague what does undeserving
even mean on a scale of super bowl 41
peyton manning to green book
exactly how undeserving is wanda and why
once you focus on albino vision's
costume crotch floss you really do feel
bad for the undeniable chafing that must
be taking place after each footfall
his poor poor underbits is it really you
asks the mind reader easily capable of a
quick scanneroo
why is caucasian here pretending like he
cares about wanda at all instead of just
sneaking up on her and taking her out
and i was told she is which is why this
damsel in distress setup is all the more
infuriating
deus ex ocula i can fix it can you
yes she can wanda builder
jeez disney you don't even own that
property there's nothing sacred
like pretty much every villain before
him robo blanco just saunters out of a
fire after hanging out there for a while
and waiting for the conversation to in
before attacking you could almost make
an excuse for humans who may want a
showboat but he's a computer with a
directive deit
it wouldn't be a marvel property without
same fighting same in the finale
complete with quick cuts in cg
and with wanda and agatha later it
happens twice here i thought this show
might escape those tropes but nope
proverbs 26 11 comes through again and
no i'm not gonna look it up for you and
yes
it does include a puke reference because
the bible is hardcore like that
you must be destroyed and so we watch
vision have his forehead bling yanked
out again
hey good thinking viz and why did you do
that last time
hey it's my favorite member of the
bureau who i had brought here to mission
control
instead of locked in a room for some
reason no one sees this
including the security details standing
directly behind him
are we sure suare doesn't stand for some
worthless oblivious random dudes
you could be a part of that victory
jimmy if only you had a little more
vision i'll be the one to handle the
terrible name based puns around here
i'm betting he didn't put much thought
at all into that one and that's worth a
wholesome
i said they were terrible when in doubt
just break the fence for that perfect
shot
no need to make it look like the fence
has flaws in other places nope just make
your hero face hole and call it a day
did you know there's an entire chapter
devoted to you
in the dark hole i got the slacks off on
enunciating the d and for a second i
thought the book of the damned was
called the dark hole
which if it hadn't already been the name
of my high school hyper pop band might
have actually been better
oh good i'm not the only person that
keeps an eight and a half by eleven head
shot of myself in my man cave i was
teased relentlessly by my dude bros but
honestly you never know when you need
one
ralph boner boner
no a thousand times no first if your
name is boner you've heard this joke a
million times and are not gonna beavis
your response to your own name
second why does ralph only have super
speed in that necklace if she was using
him anyway why didn't you give him other
powers like super strength or even a
smidgen of intelligence
why not fully use the power of boners to
your advantage agatha
and finally the fact that you look
exactly like pietro from another movie
that was all the coincidence
i'm the fan and you must submit to all
my theories on the multiverse and
mutants and i wrote a whole thesis
already and how dare you act like this
is your story to tell when my mind was
already made up
my husband's on a business trip tell him
i love him
this brings up a good point how are
there not hundreds of loved ones outside
this town that haven't been able to
reach their children spouses parents
college buddies etc
wouldn't those people have contacted the
authorities your grief is poisoning us
i trust your metaphor when you can just
have your characters explicitly spell it
out
anyone else worried about mr hart he
never shows up again after the first
episode and now i'm wondering if he
tried to eat steak again when vision
wasn't around to do a metaphysical
tracheotomy
if you won't let us go just let us die
please i will wait what i will let you
go
oh i thought this was actually about to
get fresh and interesting again
head laser head laser head laser head
laser head laser
excitement you tied your family to this
twisted world
now one can't exist without the other
thanks for breaking this emotional
moment up by having a character
explicitly lay out what we already know
why won't you trust me marvel i've been
watching the whole time
look i don't mind a bit of an homage but
this is so the incredibles they should
have to pay whatever company owns pixar
some royalties for this
not to beat a dead vision here but how
does any of this fight make any sense
if they can phase through each other why
do any of their punches land ever why do
super powerful beings always end up
punching each other
why are you doing this my programming
directive is to destroy the vision
but my script directive is to pause for
philosophical conversations occasionally
as well
i request elaboration every [ __ ] fans
response after the end of this [ __ ]
episode somehow makes it into the
[ __ ] script
oh yes here's a wholesome mcu moment
where a man decides to straight up
murder some
children it's okay though because we get
to see monica's sweet powers so
nobody really cares too much but this is
still an absolute sin also that's right
monica's entire storyline about getting
her powers boils down to absorbing a few
bullets that the kids could have taken
care of themselves anyway
if you look up anti-climactic in the
dictionary it just says we were going to
put a picture of monica rambo here but
we were too bored
have fun in prison ladies and gentlemen
the entirety of darcy's finale story arc
you are familiar with the thought
experiment the ship of theseus in the
field of identity metaphysics
no but i am familiar with the
philosophical [ __ ] of plot theseus
in the field of convenient and
underwhelming story resolutions that was
easy
and so visbino flies out of the hex
without becoming damaged from the cell
restructuring properties of said hex
and then finds a simple place to destroy
himself as that is his directive
speaking of directives albion also said
he was going to destroy
wanda has that somehow changed now that
he saw her in some memories
memories which revealed that she had
once murdered him you see the difference
between you and me that you did this on
purpose
how does wanda know anything about this
moment in agatha's past did she watch
that last episode too
you are the scarlet witch
i suppose now that we're seeing a long
ago memory from agatha's past turn into
a zombie prophecy we should all jump
right in and believe whatever they say
i love you so i hurt you
this rune reveal is clever i guess
except how and when did wanda do this
how did she know how
why did she play possum and pretend to
be drained of her power how did agatha
suck all the power in if she had no
magic
how was she even flying with no magic
once wanda had the runes up there why
not just lock her down instead of
letting her enemy and her own family
think she was being destroyed first
and if she wasn't faking how did she get
her powers back
even if you think you have answers to
some of these questions this scene is
hella confusing honestly nothing makes
any sense now that the show has been
completely ruined
and red beats purple because reasons and
i'm happy i think
oh god you don't know what you've done
nope it's almost like someone should
have told her all about the pros and
cons of coming into her power before
provoking her to come unto her power but
then where would we be for all the
upcoming mcu content eh what
i assumed agatha had been fighting
barefoot this entire time you know
considering she wizard of oz her battle
boots back by the car
i'll give you the role you chose the
nosy neighbor
for how long and on what show is
westview not going back to normal
what even is this punishment should we
head on nope because you can't go home
until it's dark outside it's far more
dramatic that way haha
yes there we go instant evening your
mother and i
very proud of you both very proud and
now we're going to release you to the
existential nothingness even though we
could probably simply leave the bubble
intact over just our house
enjoy annihilation toodles it's somewhat
believable that the very logical vision
would embrace his impending death with a
sort of casual wilp
but the kids were to believe they hunker
down in bed after a mad rush of
superpower adrenaline all day
mom and dad are like well we love you
good night and the boys just closed
their eyes and asked zero questions
about the collapsing glowing wall or
why they were being disintegrated
earlier mcu said
skip you vision
are the piece of the mind stone that
lives in me
oh who knows what i might be next
a plot convenience i'm calling it
i'm not crying you're crying no
seriously i'm not crying because despite
this entire series supposedly being
about grief and letting go we end up
with another vision in the world with
the memories of the real vision and
there are never actual consequences for
anything
for dramatic sake it sure is good all
these people just hung around out here
instead of running to call loved ones or
running away from the giant witch battle
for shelter or any of a number of other
things that actual humans would do in
this situation
also fine what wanda did was super
[ __ ] up whether she meant to or not
but is
anyone going to ask her for a new town
pool before she goes
they'll never know what you sacrificed
for them oh come on
she didn't sacrifice anything for them
she created this whole thing and sunken
placed them into her fantasy having her
nightmares and her loss had already
happened before they even entered the
picture
wanda is the villain pure and simple you
know it
i know it i'm just wondering if marvel
will ever know it given the chance and
giving your power i'd bring my mom back
then you've learned nothing and none of
us have learned anything and
why did we even all go through this
[Music]
that's it that's it what about all the
winks at the multiverse the fox universe
x-men the aerospace engineer
nexus it's one thing to have reveals
that may be a bit underwhelming but it's
another thing to leave
every single loose thread that you
specifically dangled hanging
there are so many unconsummated teases
in this show that they should have just
titled the final episode plot blocked
also what about the whole tv show
concept i may have been wrong about a
couple things the created by wandavision
sin and thinking the messenger was in on
it come to mind but the vast majority of
the observations still ring true
how was she controlling the episodes
were they airing in real time
why did she even air them in the first
place why didn't she do a who's the boss
episode what was
up with those commercials who aired
those and were those people in the town
and what about beekeeper guy
for the love of god how did she rewind
time and what does that mean happen to
beekeeper guy
so fine take a couple sins back for the
times i was wrong
but i'm adding another 10 cents for the
times i was right then here's an extra 5
just for beekeeper guy
he'd like to meet with you where
the theater addict
[Music]
multitasking
you naughty naughty you teasing me you
naughty
[Music]
i know the stereotype i'm a woman
got a luscious body provocative clothes
i'm gonna use sex to sell cars
oh no i'm not single oh i don't see a
ring
mind your own goddamn business gene what
is the purpose of this company
i don't want to sell anything buy
anything or process anything as a career
hello peter what's happening what about
seduction techniques
this is the
essence of sex
this is taking too long i'm gonna miss
the farmer's market
from meatloaf to cherry pie to
open-faced cheese sandwiches
mmm open-faced club sandwich our
anniversary
our anniversary what oh
all of this is for the children for the
children
you know for kids you both have severe
psychological problems and i
see i'm i'm i'm i'm the nice one here
how is anybody doing this sober just one
more drink
i'll cut off your touch with a knife you
[ __ ] i too
have some top secret gossip to share i'm
i'm taking it in my butt
i can't help but wonder if you and i
haven't gotten off on the wrong foot
dottie and i would like to correct that
if i can
and how would you do that look daddy i
like you
like i like you pop quiz wanda
there's a bomb on a bus once the bus
goes 50 miles an hour
the bomb is armed phil
do these earrings make me look fat you
just answer
it's like a reflex do i look fat no yes
i know what you mean
if you judge your friends for passing
judgment on you you're not only judging
yourself
you're judging your friends for judging
you and that would be using bad judgment
honeydew you don't get a plus one
cantaloupe
pregnancy sucks making a human being
is really hard i have no control over my
body or
my emotions scare bear i'm sorry all i
want to do is punch in the face
but i love you so much you have an agent
today go [ __ ] yourself
what about you i've got a butthole and
it's working overtime
careful rambo they drew first blood not
me
wow i mean
whoa
we have to go back kate mommy daddy
come and play with us daddy
[Music]
cowabunga dude dad i've never said
cowabunga in my life
your script sucks what happened to him
found him in my azalea bushes don't know
how many leaves he ate i didn't find him
until it was too late
siri how do you perform cpr
on a
[Music]
halloween's dog magical holiday all
about family
friends and the thrill of getting to be
someone else for a day
wrong don't you know what happens on
halloween
you are incorrigible darling i know a
secret thing for mexican
wrestlers sometimes you wear stretchy
pants
in your room he's for fun i smell dino
success
really cause i smell baked crotch can
balls fart because i feel like i'm
smelling that too
right on little dude whoa you must have
been booking how fast do you think you
were going
i am locutous aboard
resistance is futile
only i didn't say fudge i said the
word
actually did bite a kid once i know that
babies taste best
i see dead earthly people
of knowing which direction we are going
bring back the balance ray as i did in
the night
and i killed your little dog
so what i see here is a baby witch
obsessed with sitcoms and years of
therapy ahead of her
you stay in this dimension too long your
body's going to disintegrate
and i for one can't wait to watch
the only way forward is bad
that doesn't make sense you're social
slip in the juice
i watched the entire autopsy of this
creature pretty much
that the public has since come to know
as the alien autopsy it's okay baby it's
a beautiful beautiful beautiful pair of
twins
did you nurse children so you want to
play rough
do you
it really was no miracle what happened
was just this
i'm touching your head you're bluffing
mr son of a [ __ ] let's play some
cards nice tricks i've been led to
understand that tricks
are exclusively for children
i just wanted to see you clearly
good luck and remember
don't pick it up